okay so we are back with our Back to the
Future breakdowns as always I'm your
host Paul and welcome to the heavy
spoilers show there's that word again
heavy why are things so heavy in the
future is there a problem with the
Earth's gravitational pole so like the
the spoilers are heavy but like they
don't weigh anything look you don't care
what you do care about though is our
track through this time traveling
classic you it we're going to be
breaking down the Easter eggs making of
trivia and everything you need to know
about the film and its Legacy if you
missed our first one then that's on
screen right now and in it we touched
upon what a success it was spending 3
months at the top of the box office a
sequel was put into production faster
than 88 mph with both Fox and Lloyd
signing on instantly according to IMDb
trivia Fox saw the tub continued which
was added to the VHS of the first one
and immediately rang his agent to make
sure he was included that's now since
been removed but it did tease out the
studios's confidence in the franchise
you have to remember this was a time
before Studios announced 800 movies in a
shared Universe before they'd even made
the first one and thus this was a big
thing for fans of the film meeting back
up with screenwriter Bob Gail robbert
zus hit the ground running but instantly
they were filled with regret realizing
they left Jennifer and the car at the
end of the first one they knew they'd
have to come up with a story that
involved her too you can kind of tell
that they wanted her out the way as soon
as we hit 2015 as she shoved out the way
then gets picked up goes back to the 80s
and then gets shoved out the way again
neither of the creators had actually
ever planned a sequel and that line
about the kids was supposed to just end
that movie with a joke so getting her
out the way became very important to
them and it does kind of slow down the
pacing of the film now though the future
seemed like the next logical step Gail
took other approaches in the early
drafts the first one was going to take
place mainly in the late 60s with
Lorraine as a flower child protesting
the war George is also going to be
working at Berkeley with him being a
professor that specialized in literature
the first film ended with his debut book
getting published which had many
wondering why it took so long George had
obviously been desperate to be a science
fiction writer so this helped to explain
why only dropped his first one in the
80s those zamus was working on Who
Framed Roger Rabbit he started to come
up with his own ideas zcas thought they
could just revisit the first film and
show the events from another Angle now
in our first video we talked about the
issues with Eric stalls who was
originally in the role of Marty the
casting curse carried over to this to
with Cris and Glover refusing to sign on
on the first film he disagreed about the
ending which painted wealth is leading
into happiness the reason that I didn't
end up being in the film it's it's more
complex than this but I I was asking
questions the there that the produ The
Producers director didn't like Glover
took issue with a prize at the end being
a truck when he thought that love should
be the film's message he thought that
morally this taught the wrong lessons
but reluctantly shot it after being shut
down according to Glover this led to
friction with seus and by the the time
the second film rolled around this all
spilled over Glover apparently wanted a
million for his role and after this was
denied the role was then recast in the
film we see Jeffrey wisman who's been
done up to look like Glover with them
also employing archival footage to help
be up the role Glover has denied that
the dispute was overpay and said he only
got offered
$125,000 what what happened in the
negotiation was I I actually wanted to
be in the film uh but the uh the off
[Music]
was less than half of what Leah Thompson
and Tom Wilson who had similar sized
roles sure and it just it wasn't fair
according to kider he's refused to
attend any cast meetings with him solely
placing the blame on Bob Gale kider have
said that Gail doesn't know why it's
falling on him as both zamus and
Spielberg were involved with the recast
there are negative things that have been
said to me and then about me on the
Blu-rays that are are are not true and
uh oh a commentary really yeah yeah he
said things that are like I mean I
haven't listened to it all in completion
myself but I've had people come up and
say did this this and this I said where
did you hear that and they said on the
on the commentary on the Blu-ray for
Back to the Future and and uh it's
always from him I it's not from Roberts
zus it's not I mean Steven Spielberg
doesn't comment at all but but any
anything Bob Gil still is that's his
main um career at this point either way
this eventually led to a lawsuit with
Glover saying they used his likeness
without getting his permission this
entire thing was resolved outside of
court but it's been a major turning
point in actor's likeness right side
contracts now make it so you can't use
an actor's likeness without a first at
least getting their consent now whether
they agreed with him or not I think the
idea of wealth is something that the
film very heavily grapples with the
sports Alman Arch is something Marty
wants to use to make money but in the
end it just causes lots of issues so
though glove app didn't appear in the
film You could argue there was some
influence over the things he brought up
last time on top of this Claudia Wells
left the film too which meant they had
to reshoot the opening with Elizabeth's
shoe more like Elizabeth
re-shoot anyway Wells was more to do
with personal issues with her actually
voluntarily leaving the role
unfortunately her mother was Ill with
cancer and Wells chose to look after her
instead of being in the film Wells ended
up providing a voice for the Back to the
Future game though and in the end it's
all Wells and
done now because of the issues with
Glover they were hit with a snag but in
many ways it helped to develop the
script killing George he could be absent
from the alternate timeline and does not
have to appear after his scene early on
this would make Biff seem even more
Sinister and give line way more to do to
keep production cost down they also shut
it back toback with part three and
that's they figured out how to exercise
George from the plot without causing
issues so off they were to 2015 for part
to the land of hoverboards and flying
cars now so obviously none of this [__]
happened but how did they get it all so
wrong you should be ashamed to yourself
absolutely ashamed I ain't going to lie
I'm getting
cooked well Blade Runner right that
actually played a big part with them
basing the technology of what was in
that blade runers of course set in 2019
so I just dial it back four years mate
and you get the idea Zas actually said
at the time he was worried about the
future because he knew deep down they'd
make it inaccurate predictions on the
30th anniversary of the blu-ray releases
though they actually made a sure and in
the end they explained it all title Doc
Brown Saves the World it features a
message explaining what happened this
had the doc saying that he traveled out
to 2040 and discovered something wrong
in the tech of the past or the future at
the time hoverboards and dehydrated food
made everyone over Wade and on top of
this the world itself had ended why well
because the Mr Fusion the bloody Mr
Fusion that had a glitch that cus caused
a nuclear Holocaust that destroyed the
planet thus he ended up going back to
2015 and stopped all this stuff from
ever being invented so in the end that's
why we don't have it now and i' actually
do quite like that they went and cleared
that all up anyway that's all the making
of trivia that you need to know now
let's break down back to the feature 2
Electric
[Music]
Baloo the movie begins on October 26th
1985 with a shot for shot remake of how
the original movie ended we placed these
scenes together so you can see how they
line up and it was obviously due to the
whole Jennifer recasting thing obviously
they're not going to get everything back
on because it's so difficult to
recapture these moments perfectly if
you're going to jump over to this
immediately from that stuff will stick
out like the rain's breasts what but on
the whole they do get it pretty close
however a couple of cool little details
that I noticed here that the license
plate on the Toyota changes in the
second film originally it was 2 easp 916
rier it's two back 860 I was wondering
if the two back was a reference to this
being the second Back to the Future but
unfortunately I couldn't find anyone on
the commentary confirming it however I
think that's the case now in case you
missed our last breakdown we also see
Doc Brown going through the trash and
can catch a can of Miller High Life this
was known as the champagne of beers and
it was supposed to show George had gone
up in the world as before this the can
Biff grabbed was just your box standard
Miller Light we also see the Mr Fusion
on top of the car which was a prop that
also shot up in Alien later on when we
get to the Future you can also catch
Fusion Industries in the back alley as
the DeLorean reverses out we can also
see it's got a barcode for the license
play and they also add in a scene of
Biff spotting the DeLorean takeoff now
for the title sequence we get a point of
view shot for what's likely meant to be
the car moving through the clouds
according to the good Folks at IMDb This
was originally shot for a film called
fire Fox that was starring none other
than Clint Eastward which wasn't a mod
usess in part three when he travels to
the Past later on when we see Biff in
the H tub we can also catch him watching
a fist full of dollars this foreshadows
what happens in part three as mod uses
the same trick here and the shootout
with beefer tannan amongst the names
you'll also see Billy Zayn who returns
once more for the role of match for that
movie he wasn't really a know actor but
for this film he' established himself a
lot still though he decided to return to
the movie and even though he knew it a
small role he did it because this helped
to build his name as the car comes in
they pass by the sign for the courthouse
square with this apparently being a
nightmare to assemble why we stop asking
that I'll tell you like when well back
when they filmed the first movie they
built it as the pristine 1955 version
first they then shot those scenes and
messed up the set so that they could
then shoot the stuff for the beginning
and the end however when they went to
shoot part two they had to match it to
be the same as the first film and
according to the wiki it costs them more
to rebuild it than what it would have
cost to build it all from scratch the
courthouse of course appears throughout
the trilogy with it being a landmark
that they had to style and rebuild
several times over something else that
fits the Blade Runner aesthetic is the r
that's constantly beating down on the
car La lovely La it's meant to be a
paradise where the beer flows like wine
and the Sun never stops shining BL
Runner had it pouring to show how much
humans had affected the planet or R yeah
it's controlled by the weatherman This
was meant to poke fun at Al line in part
one when Doc Brown thought that a storm
was in coming are you sure about this
storm since where can weather men
predict the weather as they move towards
the square we can also see a hyperlane
phoenix Boston and London this shows
just how much travel has advanced with
people now being able to drive across
the planet as they turn in we see the
Hill Valley sign with Goldie Wilson Jr
now being the Met Goldie was someone we
met in part one with his election Vans
being about in 1985 the tag Line's also
back to being a nice place to live which
was what it was was during 1955 in the
80s they didn't have that but this shows
how the reputation's been restored when
you think about it there's really three
versions of the town with the first one
being the Twin Pines mall one this is
then altered into the more idolic one at
the end before it's then transformed
into the the nightmare timeline because
of Biff tannning that second one's what
we witnessing the branch of here so
maybe that's why they included that
tagline under it they've also changed
your typical warning signs which
normally say stuff like please drive
safely seat belts save lives here though
nice little joke with them changing it
to fly safely and ejection seats save
lives upon Landing doc says b the post
office isn't as efficient as a Weather
Service which kind of foreshadows the
two things that affect him throughout
the film Doc is sent back in time by the
weather and he also uses the Postal
Service to send a letter to
Marty doc then ends up peeling off his
skin which we learn was because of a
Rejuvenation Clinic this was carried out
because of practical reasons and so that
Christopher Lloyd wouldn't have have to
constantly wear old man makeup you also
see Marty getting some self lacing Nikes
which the company made for real during
2015 to afford them though you're going
to need the almanac cuz right now A pair
will set you back about 13 Grand the
ones from the movie sold for 70 GS I'm
going to have to do a lot of sponsorship
deals to pay for that which yeah time
for the sponsorship part of the video
Hey Now today's video is sponsored by
rocket money so recently we just moved
into a new house but we're already
saving for an extension cuz the two
little on they're running wild they're
coming in they're not knocking me toys
Off the Wall getting on top of your
expenses is very important especially in
the new year and that's where rocket
money come in rocket money is the
personal finance app that helps you
cancel subscriptions lower bills and
manage your money better now covering
movies and TV shows I've got tons of
different subscriptions but a lot of the
time I'm not actually using them rocket
money safely and securely identifies
recurring charges and cancels unwanted
subscriptions without any hassle you can
even cancel from within in the app with
just a couple of TAPS so you no longer
have to worry about those long customer
service calls and on average rocket
money saves $720 for every customer per
year simply by uploading a photo of your
bill and tapping a few buttons rocket
money will negotiate your bills for you
from internet service to cable and phone
bills it also analyzes your spending
habits and creates custom budgets to
manage your lifestyle you can
automatically monitor your spending
category and get notifications once
you've exceeded your limit you can also
set up smart savings which allows you to
choose the amount in frequency and
Rocket money will automatically deposit
savings into a smart savings account
which you can withdraw anytime take
control of your finances today just go
to Rocket money.com heavys spoilers and
get started with rocket money for free
start your free trial today save more
spend less and huge thank you to Rocket
money for sponsoring today's video
thanks at this point Mod's given a
jacket and tell to pull his pockets out
because that's what all kids do in the
future along with thumbs uping the
videos he's also given in a cap and
looks almost identical to his son except
for he has blue eyes whereas his sons
are brown dumping Jennifer ducklin shows
him a a newspaper which actually has
some really cool little details on it in
the top left we can see the sports
section and this starts off with a game
called slam ball this was originally
going to be in the film but
unfortunately they had to cut it due to
budgeting reasons you also see the curbs
sweep the series in five which is
summing up foreshadows the whole Sports
Almanac thing Gail put it in as a joke
and though he got that wrong he did in
the end get something right Gale
correctly predicted Miami would have a
baseball team by 2015 which is something
that shows up in the film last see on
the right hand side we can see
Washington prepares for Queen Diana's
visit as she was of course expected to
stay with Charles and Rule as we know
her life was sadly cut short in 1997
during a car crash while she was out in
Paris as Marty pulls it in we also get a
better look at the news line column with
the first line being about the thumb
bandits in the future you pay by
fingerprint and they amputated some
someone's arm in order to get the money
we can also catch one that says Tokyo
stocks up which was put in there due to
Japan's strong economy this confirmation
of a madame president with a headline
saying she's tired and the USA Today
also says it has three billion readers
hinting at how much the populations
grown lastly we can see in the top right
that it cost $6 which is of course due
to inflation the price of things going
up was earlier hinted at by doc who
gives Marty 50 bucks just to buy a Pepsi
go in and order a Pepsi here's a 50 now
the reason junior is jailed is because
lawyers have been abolished in the
future and thus the legal system works a
lot quicker we learn M's daughter also
tried to bust out her brother and thus
this entire event destroys the whole
family at this point mty heads into the
square and we watch as he walks past the
reelection posters these are done in a
similar style to how Goldie Senor had
them showing that it's like father like
son as he walks forward we can catch a
poster on the left before two people
walk out with a hover surfboard later on
we get a better look at this sign and
can see it says surf Vietnam this was a
little not to Apocalypse Now without
ripping off the surfing scenes that
happened in that film we've done a big
breakdown on that if you want to check
it out and I think it's one of the best
videos on the channel so do it and tell
the people you enjoyed it as well you
better anyway from here mody goes to the
Hollow max which is showing jaw's 19
this is directed by Max Spielberg with
the tagline being this time it's really
really personal Universal as much has
slag them off by their copyright strikes
actually put out a really funny trailer
in 2015 telling the story of the
franchise up until that point Jaws made
you afraid to go in the
water Jaws 2 made you afraid to go back
in the water jaws 3D was a new dimension
in Terror in Jaws 4 the Revenge it was
personal then it was just business then
Pure Pleasure cyber Jaws made you afraid
to log on and Robo Jaws made you afraid
of robotic sharks then Chief Brody's
grandson assembled a super team of shark
Hunters Jaws 10 it was Man versus Shark
versus all the Terrors of the deep outer
space then a prequel and a sequel to the
prequel and then a new era in Terror
began Jaws started a family battled a
Russian shark named Ivan shovsky took a
bite out of the Big Apple and learned
about love from a mysterious stranger
Jaws 18 Origins the mind-blowing reboot
now the oceans are dis appearing and to
save their home the Sharks must attack
Jaws 19 this time it's really really
personal Stevenson Max was born in 1985
without also being the year that the 80s
scenes happened in now Back to the
Future 2 of course gets reference in end
game when anman calls it a bunch of
[__] however beyond that we have a
little ND at this scene with the
Leviathan that's killed in Tony snap one
ends up disappearing just before go to E
rocket with it being shot at the same
angle that we get this hologram shark
still looks fake that line was also not
Spielberg who who was frustrated the
shark Bruce looks so fake and Jaws that
they had to cut around it in the end it
made it more terrifying but that movie
was said to be a nightmare film and one
day I promise that'll cover it either
way Mar also looks up at the Texico
garage which has been a main stay in the
Square this appeared at the same spot
during the 80s and was also there during
1955 at this point Goldie junor pops up
advertising the hover conversion ad
which we can see shows a pink car this
ends up driving just another sign and we
see it for real as it passes by below it
the square also has little time travel
jokes as we can catch a ret Ro store
with a clock on the sign to the left of
Cafe 80s beside the goldie ad we can
also catch one which I can't quite make
out the name but it says travel under it
now why I'm pointing this out is because
it's in the same spot that Mr Foster's
travel store was at in the ' 50s which
had the line time to travel mod ends up
going to the window of the antique one
and we also get a lots of things from
the era there's Jaws one and two on VHS
as well as a lava lamp and JFK bust
above that we can also catch Roger
Rabbit with Zas of course Direct in that
movie the film gets a further reference
later on with a tunnel being the same
one that takes you to Toontown in the
top left there's also a denim Shir which
is actually Mar's one from the first
film if you go back to that movie you
can see has a badge on that says art and
Revolution which this one also carries
on top of this there's a guitar pin tag
and I'm telling you it's a bloody same
shirt and Morty did leave it is it a
jacket it's a bloody jacket either way
Marty did leave it on his bed in the 80s
so maybe this is a carryover from that
lastly is a JBC camera and though it's
not the same as the one in the first
film mod did use a camera from the same
company now at this point we hit Cafe 8s
and catch two guitars on the wall one of
these would later be played by Marty
during the scene after which he gets
fired we also to get one of many Michael
Jackson references with a song Beat It
playing in the back as you spin around
we as likeness is used for the waer with
Jackson happily handing this over
Jackson was apparently such a big fan of
the first film that he was extremely
eager to be included in this movie in
the end they used one of his tribute
acts who went by the name e Casanova
this point he was seen as the world's
number one impersonator so it's a pretty
cool inclusion to have him in the film
later on at the Alternet McFly house his
posters L of the room and I counted six
things yes six things for him hanging up
on the wall there's a Thriller album
cover which is over a poster of him and
then on the side we've got one for off
the- wall on the door is a poster for
the Thriller video and in the mirror we
can catch a bigger version of the album
cover now we also see a max headro style
Ronald Reagan with Reagan of course
getting mentioned in the first film you
might also notice there's some moving
stars and stripes in the background
which came from the Coca-Cola ad Max
Headroom for president Marty then ends
up getting a Pepsi perfect with him
attempting to order a Pepsi during the '
50s one thing they got right is that on
the menu they had the product Pepsi Max
which wouldn't come to be invented in
until 1993 anyway we then get across to
Biff and watch as he stands about the
booth to the left of him we can catch
the LA Times which was reporting on
Reagan's second term terms later get
brought up in the film as we learn that
Richard Nixon's serving a fifth one in
the nightmare timeline we then get of
the first movie with Biff continuing to
berate the mcfli hello hello anybody
home huh think McFly think hello hello
anybody home huh think McFly think until
Monday hello hello anybody home I think
with flying thing this point we then get
this hey GRS I told you two coats of wax
on my car not just one calling back to
this line from the first film uh now
beff I want to make sure that we get two
coats of wax this time not just one
don't bloody try and C me Biff anyway
Griff Chucks them out and in the corner
we can see the wild gunman is that
that's bloody Elijah would that that's
Elijah W now now this would be the the
actor's first role and both he and
Michael J fox would end up working
together with Peter Jackson Fox ended up
doing The Frighteners and would have
course worked on the Lord of the Rings
mody shows his a crack shot and in part
three he'd end up blasting away with a
real gun in the wild wild west now
although wild Gman is a real game there
was never an arade cabinet for it the
graphics we also see were created just
for the movie with the real one looking
slightly different at this point Junior
stumbles in and we get a line that flips
things from the film been Sunday oh mfly
your shoes on
TI
McFly your shoes
un don't be so gullible McFly I don't
want to see you in here again I thought
I told you to stay in here here we also
meet the girl of the group darene who
stunt double Cheryl Wheeler Duncan had a
nasty accident in the crash scene she
was supposed to go into the glass but
she ended up smacking into the concrete
pillar though they cut it just before
she drops you can clearly see her
smacking up against it sh then fell 30
ft and shattered both her wrist and face
ouch now Griff calls my a chicken which
makes them turn around and they kind of
use this as a way throughout the films
de bait him into doing stuff to be
honest I always kind of thought it was
stupid but they at least Bring It full
circle in the third film when he decides
to stop caring which helps him evade the
crash that would have changed his life
now outside mod manages to snatch a
hoverboard which is probably this
movie's most iconic piece of tech this
was originally going to be made by
Swatch but Mattel stepped in and secured
the deal zus had a laugh when promoting
the movie as he said Mattel had made
them but they just hadn't put them into
production yet he said that they managed
to secure some for the film and that
they were going to be available very
very soon now what a [__] [__]
mate I'm I'm bloody Furious I bet Matel
were too as they were constantly
inundated with calls asking to buy one
for the film though they were pretty
straightforward with the boards
themselves just being planks of wood Fox
had to have his feet harnessed into the
board itself which meant that in the
scenes he rides one he was securely
attached thus between takes he had to be
carried back and forth with the board
still being stuck there at the time it
was reported that due to the foer gap
between films that fox had forgotten how
to ride one and that he had to learn how
to ride one again however fox has since
St this was an early symptom of his
Parkinson's disease which would later be
diagnosed just two years later we also
see Griff getting out his and if you
look close you can see it's called
Pitbull this was originally going to be
named Mad Dog after buer tannan but they
felt that it was a bit too on the nose
still though this scene is brilliant
especially if you just watched part one
with it ripping heavily on what happened
in that we even have Marty hitching onto
a car just like how he did in that first
film causing the gang to crash in the
courthouse the Futures changed and
Junior is saved Marty then goes to give
the girl a board but she says that she's
now got a pitbull this is playing off
the scene in the first film and which
Mar gave a young a young Tony Hawk let's
call him his very first skateboard now
at this point similar to 1985 we see
someone stepping forward to try to get
mody to save the clock tower whereas in
that though the ledge was fine here we
can see that it's now missing this is of
course because of Doc Brown's actions
which caused it to Fall Away in 1955
gorsa says lightning struck that thing
60 years ago wait a minute now you don't
have to have wasted your life being a
movie YouTuber to get that one and at
this moment Marty sees the Cubs
announcement he gets the idea from Terry
to go back in time and use a sports
almanar to make money money
money now when looking at Terry here
yeah I always wondered why the makeup
was so bad but right when digging around
I found out the reason turns out there's
a deleted scene where Terry argues with
Biff about an unpaid car repair Bill
Terry said he remembered the exact date
he didn't pay him which was November
12th
1955 this is what made Biff remember the
exact date so he knew when exactly to
travel back to Biff screwing over Terry
with and get a kic response with him
then leter crashing into manure again
right after the dance anyway we then go
to the shop and get what turns out to be
a pretty important Line This has an
interesting feature it has a dust jacket
later on the magazine gets confiscated
by strickling but we learn this is
really a Rudy Dy mag shout outs to DBZ
hero 29 on R for pting out that Biff did
this on purpose to mislead anyone that
was going to try and steal it outside
Biff then spots a DeLorean realizes that
the one from the 80s and this are the
same we to get this line I left him in a
suspended animation kennel Einstein
never knew I was gone which was just
thrown in to fill a plot hole as do Dr
off of the future with Einstein in the
car when he returned home the dog was
missing so they just put this in to
explain why he wasn't there anyway doc
then steps out a change of clothes which
has some brilliant foreshadowing on it
we can see a steam train from the wild
wild west and can also catch horses
riding alongside it this is done to
foreshadow part three in which they
hijack one from the Wild West in what's
an amazing bit of attention to detail we
see doc actually wearing the shirt
itself as a band dinner in the film when
he and Marty hold up the train as I've
been saying it's all connected and if
you want to support the channel then
pick up some of our all connected merch
which you can catch right below the
video we're also working with arrow
films and giving 10% off everything on
the site with the code heavy spoilers
it's a new year mate so why not treat
yourself and get 10% off at Arrow films
with the code heavy spoilers now ow all
connected it's all connected a junior is
saved with a seeing the USA camera drone
dropping in and taking the photo that
appears on the paper itself realizing
that he's got the almanac doc then goes
to benett which is when we see Jennifer
getting picked up the officer on the
right's actually played by Mary Ellen
trainer who at the time was Z's real
wife but then preoccupied with that Biff
then puts his plan into action and we
catch the police car driving to hildale
as they Shine the flashlight at lights
up the sign and we can see what the
tagline for the area is was supposed to
to be the address of success but bloody
vandals have changed that to suckers
sort of hints to how Mar's life's turned
out and we learn that the area is a
pretty rough neighborhood be careful in
the future uh I get it did you get that
life hasn't turned out how they expected
though with a pair getting married in a
chapelo love they also have to watch the
scenery channel so the Allure of the
almanac becomes even more Michael even
ends up playing his daughter and luckily
it's so distracting you don't even
realize that that's not crisping when
Jennifer first comes in she also says
mom Mom is that you I got to get out of
here which is the same line spoken by
mty when he wakes up confused about
where he is in the first film in the car
we see his dock grabs onto his visor and
says that he thinks he sees a taxi
following at this point you can also
clearly spotty has two wrist watches on
showing how obsessed with time that he
is back in the house we learn that M
bust up the scenery screen after the guy
who installed it called him chicken and
we learn how much this word is very
triggering for him about about 30 years
ago your father tried to prove he wasn't
chicken and he ended up in an automobile
accident Oh you mean with the rolls Roy
this rolls Roy pops up at the end of
part three and shows how he narrowly
managed to avoid that path now when
Junior returns home we see how he turns
on some channels and in the top right we
can see one for breasts and plants
potentially this is foreshadowing what
Lorraine would be forced into and she
ends up getting them in the alterate
timeline this timeline then gets created
when we watch Biff taking the DeLorean
Biff doing this is given away when we
see the inside of the car later on as we
can catch the date last visited on the
bottom line had they picked up on this
then they'd have realized someone else
had been in the car and instantly figure
out exactly what had happened back in
the house we see them cooking a pizza
which has the pizza hot logo on the
front of the packet now according to BB
trivia Pizza Hut wanted the brand to
look good so they provided a
professional food stylist for each and
every take they also installed a proper
Pizza Kitchen at the South and made up
new ones for every single shot at this
point he egged on by needles who's
played by flea from the Red Hot Chili
Peppers this is immediately caught by
the boss and he's fired on the spot and
there's a little detail like gives away
needles was in on it as we can catch him
looking off as the call ends which is
likely to the boss McFly's boss is also
Japanese which was due to the country's
dominance when it came to Industry this
was in a time in which lots of our items
were made in Japan and both this and
Blade Runner predicted them being world
leaders in technology I thing at the
heart of this though is that it hammers
the message of the movie which is about
the dangers of trying to get rich quick
Marty junor is arrested because he goes
in on the scheme and Marty of course
tries to grab the almanac here we also
see him getting rubbed into doing it
again and all of the outcomes just lead
to disaster Jennifer then encounters
itself we see his Biff rolls in and in a
nice bit of attention to detail you can
catch ice coming off the top of the car
like how it did in part one doc also
foreshadows his actions in the future as
he talks about going back to the old
west my only regret is that I'll never
get a chance to visit my favorite
historical era the old west he says this
is to study the greatest mystery in the
universe women without basically being
what his Arc centers around in part
three we can also catch Biff thrashing
away which is of course because he got a
raised from time now because of this
people have wondered why that Biff's
still not around technically he would
still exist after the time change he'd
just be different to the old man that he
was here gayen zc has actually put
things in place clear this up and they
were going to reveal something in an
earlier draft we would learn that
Lorraine shot Biff in '96 which
explained why the biffs start a vanish
like my subscribers now that comic book
movies are on popular returning back to
1985 there is a couple of signs straight
away that something a Miss as they pull
in we can see a battered car in a
driveway and trash piling out of every
bin as they go to drop Jennifer off we
can also see a total car on hers with
bars on the Windows now what I love well
I shouldn't say love what I find funny
is that they just drop Jennifer off on
her porch leave her there and say uh if
we sort stuff out it'll be fine mate no
need to worry about Jennifer just leave
her on the porch in hell and go change
the timeline and in the end it look
it'll just work itself out like come on
mate I don't know if that would be the
case and I would have found it hilarious
if they got Claudia Wells back to show
up in part three like nothing was wrong
but alas they don't do that and they
just dump her in the bad timeline we
then get over to L state which is filled
with graffiti and stray dogs we can also
catch multiple for sale signs outside
every house and it looks like these
belong to Biff though they're difficult
to make out that does look like his logo
and Mar's the only one without a sign
outside of it oh right you keep running
sucker and you tell that realy cominging
that I ain't selling you here does this
make sense with Biff taking over the
town I feel like the Family scene is
kind of playing off the Peabody scene in
which he gets chased into the night he
ends up making it out to stricklands who
holds him up at gunpoint and and in the
end we discover the school burned down
in the 4K version you can make out
there's a scar over his eyes and then
his house is shut up showing what Biff's
leadership's like Hill Valley has become
hell Valley and we once more get a
return of red
Thomas crazy drunk
driver watch where you're going crazy
drunk
pedestrian in case you missed our last
video red was the mayor in 1955 who
ended up homeless after losing his job
the clock tower has now been turned into
a monument to Biff but hey at least at
least he fixed the ledge still out the
strip clubs are in Full Effect tanks are
on the street and we discover that
smoking is required if you want to go
inside seeing his black car outside the
hotel we then learn of Biff's life since
the timeline change we also get a moment
showing Buford Tannon setting up the
third film's villain he ends up looking
a bit different how he does in part
three with this being an early makeup
test dub the luckiest man on Earth he's
used his fortune to legalize gabbling
and in the end has managed to build an
Empire dating Marilyn Monroe he ended up
marrying his high school sweetheart
which even old Biff still had his eye on
Hey kid say hello to your grandma for
me say hi your mom for me grabb by
matches 3D and the other one we then see
as Mar escorted upstairs you can't catch
that 3D is once more wearing 3D glasses
but in the ' 50s these were made of cod
man's now going up in the world though
as he has proper frames for this and
match also still has this match in his
mouth and we then get this bit we can do
this for easy way or the hard way the
easy way always kind of made me wonder
who was saying the easy way but shout
outs to Nile 7658 on red a for pointing
this out if you speed up the easy way
bit you can actually hear it's Michael J
fox the easy way well so I love how the
easy way is just knocking him out cuz in
the world of Biff the hard way ain't
good waking up in bed with his mother at
his side the scene of course Rifts on
the one from the first film with her
nursing him awake sat up in bed I love
how most of the actions play off that
scene with Lorraine now being scared of
beff instead of fearing her mother
line oh my God it's your
father are you up there oh my God it's
my mother living in what's got the decor
of scarface's mansion we see lra stumble
over to a lot of bottles beside this we
can catch a tape called Black Taboo
which was an adult movie that was about
I don't know why all these movies have
something like that but here we are a
[__] here we go again now we discover
that the rain wants to go Biff's Bank
rolling her kids this includes Linda who
was originally going to be a lady of the
night however wheny Joe spba was
pregnant at the time so they thought the
Optics of that it might be a bit bad you
bet you're better off just sticking with
incest mate that's much better either
way Joey is mentioned as being behind
bars with this also being a carryover
from the first film in the end M finds
out his dad's dead and we see as he goes
to visit his grave this lists his date
of birth as April 1st giving an idea
that his life was a joke you might also
notice that he died on the IDS of March
which is known as a day in which you
settle debts smart we can also see the
factories behind Marty burning in the
back showing how Biff turned it into an
industrial Wasteland joined by doc we
see a newspaper chronicling his death
and get some hints as to what the
world's like there's a stand up with
some Native Americans which was put in
place to foreshadow Mar coming across
them during part three you also see a
bit about the Watergate Revelations
which In the End changed the fate of
Nixon on the left we can see that
there's a strike with Oil Workers and a
record number of new claims for
unemployment filed the main page becomes
important as like the photograph it
shows when the future's been changed doc
then shows that in this reality he's
been committed which was something that
was foreshadowed earlier in the film
changes over the years they simply
assume she's the Jennifer of the future
well we got stop him what are we going
to say that were Time Travelers they
have us committed I know you can also
take it as Biff getting him out of the
way but I just thought that it was
interesting that they had this line
earlier either way mty flips the paper
around we get Nick in and a headline
about how there's a pollution Alert in
Hill Valley lastly if you check out the
bottom one you'll see that biffco is
taking off a Lone Pine Mall that's Lone
Pine cuz the events of the first film
still happen with George beating Biff up
about the end this is why Lorraine said
Biff would never be the man George was
because she' known him in his more
heroic Incarnation also explains why he
had him kill because George had been the
one standing up to him returning to
biffs we then get this line how'd you
get P my security downstairs and as we
see Marty came in the DeLorean
explaining how he managed to make it
past they bring up the lightning strike
the car getting rolled in manure and
also the crazy man that showed up with
the book Marty also grabbed some matches
before things lead into Biff blowing off
his gun racing downstairs I I always
appreciated how slick it was with m
jumping across staircases in order to
escape getting to the roof he manages to
make it out with the deling being held
in the a using Fiber Wire so that it
appeared invisible back in the DeLorean
we see the time circuit display flash
1885 foreshadowing where doc will go at
the end of the film arriving at line
Estates they then parked the car where
the original DeLorean was hidden at this
point though the old verion was moved to
the lab explaining why this spot is now
vacant we also get a repeat of The
Blocking that was used in part one with
one character running close to the
camera while the other runs into the
background opening up a suitcase full of
money we can also see doc has cash from
different eras when I paused this I was
wondering why there were two BS for 1864
and not being up on my American history
I did a little Google search so it turns
out this is actually due to the Civil
War which had two types of currency out
in circulation really nice attention to
detail with showing how prepared that
duck is a Biff Grandma's guu Tannon we
also hear Thomas F Wilson providing her
voice where you going B I'm going to get
my car grandma when are you coming back
cutting to the Town Square from the 50s
we see Terry with Biff arguing over the
money again this would have made more
sense with the deleted scene and explain
all that terrible old man makeup Bea
says that only he knows how to start
that car which is something older Biff
later does to get him into trusting him
this point Biff spots line who we see
excited over a New Dress this was
something that was also a bit of a
nightmare because the crew had gotten
rid of most of the clothes from the
first film this of course included
Lorraine's dresses namely the spare ones
they kept in case one got damaged
however Leah Thompson revealed that
she'd kept one and actually had to drive
home to get it for the shoot Biff
declares his love for the rain she says
she wouldn't date him even if he had a
million and you can see how those lines
play off down the line now fromia Biff's
taken to the garage in which he
interacts with his other self these
scenes were shot using the Vista Glide
which at the time was completely
groundbreaking it allowed actors to play
multiple Parts in the same scene and
have them all blend together seamlessly
b a few little moments earlier in the
movie at the mcfli we had Fox playing
three different characters in one scene
which was the first time it had ever
been pulled off in a film that shot was
divided into three parts as here they Ed
the middle of the wind screen to help
mask the coverage Biff then says now why
don't you make like a tree and get out
of here so why don't you make like a
tree and get out of
here it's leave you idiot make like a
tree and leave you sound like a damn
fool when you say it wrong Al so once
Biff correctly shows the results we can
see as the older one starts to disappear
as he hands over the book at roughly the
1 hour n Mark you can see his arm starts
to fade away this is similar how Mar's
handed in the first film showing how
things have now been changed this was
then going to be expanded on in a
deleted scene where we'd see Biff
completely disappear instead they just
had him riding around in pain but that
shows him completely feding from
existence while Einstein box at him
across town doc then talks to himself
while his past version sets up the
machine now obviously when you have
moments like this people often go back
to check if they took extras from the
background of the first film and wreck
on them to be dock going back fans have
speculated that you can catch someone in
Doc's clothes and thus I went back to
check for myself however I'm not sure if
that's the case as we can only catch two
people in a trench coat and hat one of
them is at the 1 hour 16 Mark but this
guy isn't wearing the same color as doc
the other is at 1 hour
1555 and as Mar writes a letter we can
see someone in the street who looks a
bit similar however he's not with his
bike so yeah I think people are just
dreaming dreaming like me when I said
the hand disappeared even though most
people say it's just the Vista Glide but
let me dream you anyway at the dance we
of course see George doing his best
Nutty Professor and also beffy then goes
outside reading oo la la this would end
up being what he puts the dust jacket on
when mdy goes to grab the almanac from
his pocket we can see that it doesn't
have it showing that he likely always
planned to slip this on over it this
then sends Marty on a big wild goose
chase in which he has to sneak past
himself I think it's these moments that
really make the movie work and it's so
cool seeing the first film played from
another angle as he goes to Strickland
we can also see a sign above the door
which you can see says SS Strickland now
this was obviously put in as a reference
how hard she was with it being not to
his heavy-handed totalitarian rule
however according time to be trivia it
was like later aled in the game to be
Stanford s Strickland when we learn more
about the character on his desk we can
also catch the Stars and Stripes which
has the correct 48 stars in there for
what would have been the case in 55
finally getting the book back he
realizes the truth and we sees the scene
plays out where George saves the rain
the guy says room okay A little bit of
air it's okay I know CPR I know
CPR what's CPR and this is due to this
not being invented until 1960 we then
see dark taking off in the car which
bumps against the line estate sign this
is what then triggers the malfunction
and sets the path for him to go back in
time now originally they had a seene
that tight in in the first movie and
this would be caused by old man Peabody
now the details on this are a bit
sketchy but from what I could gather
Peabody had been considered insane after
telling everyone about the town that
he'd seen a spaceship he'd be put in an
asylum but then let out which is when he
spotted the DeLorean in the sky both the
police and Peabody were then sto
shooting at it which is why it would end
up being damaged this was removed by the
time they got to the later drafts with
them simplifying it to just being a
crash Mario also has to intervene with
stopping himself from being attacked in
the past and he drops a sandbag on
Biff's gang I love how they're just
standing there waiting to beat on him
but also tapping away to the beat
because Johnny Be Good is so good you
also to see Marvin going to the phone
which as we know would be him calling up
his cousin Chuck mty makes his way
outside which is when he's confronted by
Biff and he ends up being knocked out by
his pass self exiting the building so
well put together and it just ramps up
the tension because you know that
they're on a ticking clock too chasing
him across town we hear there's an
incoming storm on the radio which as we
know would come to hit the clock tower a
severe thunderstorm is heading for Hill
Valley Marty and Biff wrestle back and
forth with a bu which then leads to Biff
getting covered in manure so from this
point onward the timelines changed and
big bad Biff would never get power he'd
never get to kill George never build the
casinos never get implicated in the list
never forced Lorraine to marry him and
never control Marty's life from this
point they then traveled back to Lon
states where both of matches and
newspaper slowly start to change this
turns Biff's Casino back to his Order
Detailing which is of course a job he
worked in the secondary timeline George
McFly is now being honored and Doc
Brown's commended instead of being
committed you can also see the Nixon to
seek a fifth term has him vowing to end
the Vietnam War by 1985 this end changes
to Reagan with biffco also being changed
to a story about the town's May however
after a lightning strike the DeLorean s
sent off into the past and at this point
we can see what looks like a burning
backwards 99 many have thought this
represents how many a were traveled but
mate I'll be honest with you the math
ain't ma since then Gail has explained
that this is because of the wheels of
the DeLorean which was spinning so fast
it caused this in the sky either way Mar
gets a letter which just so happens to
be delivered while it's raining bringing
together both a postal service and
weather like what we talked about before
guess they were efficient in the end and
they've held on to it for 70 years
revealing docks back in 1885 Mony races
back to the Clock Tower and if I was
this guy be like what I'm following him
I want to I don't want to know more here
we see his past version travel back
which of course I'm Shing guess Pauls
from the first film love the way that
they kind of play this scene out and
then just have Marty racing up to him
after he just disappeared you can spot
the fire lines when we could have the
new shot but iy I'm not mad at you and
we end with Doc fainting as as we close
out part two this then leads into a
trailer for part three showing the
frolicking Adventure that we're going to
get next I will of course be back for
that as I cannot wait to talk about this
Trilogy the film before that we're
breaking down though is another Western
well sort of and it's one of the most
requested videos on the channel That is
No Country for Old Men which I cannot
wait to talk about if you'd like to see
it early then please click the join
button below the video and with that
you'll get early access to audio and
video versions of it as well as our
podcasts called across the spiderverse
after that we'll be back to the future
and if things will go right we should
have part through out before the end of
January but the way huge thank you for
sing through this and shout out to the
Cubs for winning the series in 2016 was
in 2015 but I'll let you off and thanks
again for joining me in the video if you
want to see our breakdown on the first
film that's on screen right now and
we're that out the way I've been Paul
you've been the best and it's time to go
back to the
future
[Music]
w